32,000 more babies were born each year
for the last couple years thanks to the
do's decision thanks to the overruling
of roie Wade and the subsequent abortion
bans in various States 32,000 more
babies per year this is because of the
state abortion bands according to the
Institute of labor economics an average
of 2.3% more babies were born in states
with abortion bands compared to states
without abortion banss uh the group that
saw the largest increase in births were
women in their 20s black women and
Hispanic women what this shows you is
that people were using abortion as
contraception but furthermore what this
tells you and this is much more
important is the law is a teacher
politics is Downstream of culture sure
that's true there's there's a lot of
Truth to that it is at least as true to
say that culture is Downstream of
politics and the law is a teacher and
when you change the laws that creates
incentives and disincentives and creates
uh new kinds of behavior